because you get this patent over and
over again mathematicians like hey this
is interesting
we're going to give this pattern their
name things in not just mathematics but
in all the world every kind of stereos
though things get names when we see hey
there's something interesting here I
want to be able to describe it to
someone else right and it's something
I've never seen before
okay so this ratio in these sides
between the shortest and the longest
answer for these guys the particular
ratio we're looking at is called sign
now remember I said to you mystery
mystery number one mystery number one
was that um was why I used these ratios
would be what they are okay and the
reason for why they eyes because you're
forcing your on unintentionally creating
these similar shapes okay mystery number
two is why is this ratio called sign
I'm not explained by the end of the
lesson you need to help me again see how
we go now to be a little more specific I
am said shortest and longest sides but
there's actually something else going on
you guys just did your work on just very
recently on Pythagoras right and mr.
you're still going through that in a
right angle triangle what's the longest
side Court has a special name right it's
called the hypotenuse okay so rather
than saying shortest and longest cuz
that actually really disguises what's
going on sine of an angle right like 30
degrees that's the angle you were
looking at what it is is a ratio all of
these things are ratios between two
sides the shortest and the longest one
in our context are the longest one is
the hypotenuse and then when you have a
look at your triangles right I've
pinched the bathroom I'm going to give
it back the second we have all of your
trailers and maybe it's worth just
drawing one beside where you've got this
because that'll be useful get your right
angle there you've got the 30 degrees
we've already called this kind of
hypotenuse
the shorter side has to be the one in
this case it has to be one the one this
opposite do you see that this side he it
corresponds to this on bigger angle so
it has to be bigger as well so this is
the opposite side over here so we giving
names they sing so we can explain what
their relationships are so just to do
with sine like whoo and again I'll
explain this ratios name in a minute
it's the ratio between the opposite side
and the hypotenuse which is normal
okay so this is ringing some bells right
long CR we explore these things by the
way mathematicians lazy somewhere like
here I can make this 25 percent positive
right
so they abbreviated to that this ratio
is sign right is opposite over
hypotenuse but there are other ratios -
you didn't have to compare this pair of
sides
there's two other pairs you can have in
your triangle right but I need a name
for this other side this one down here
so this side here is right next to the
edge all you're after it's right next to
the 30 degrees okay so right next do we
use the word adjacent so sine is
relating is giving me the ratio of these
two sides right but I can talk about the
other ratios of sides and they should do
the same thing is you have the same pad
you can measure these out again if
you're really interested right we say if
instead of the opposite side and the
hypotenuse I want to compare the
adjacent side the one next to me right
so this is like the middle length side
and the hypotenuse we call this ratio
rather the side we call it career sign
right and again because we want to
abbreviate we call it cause it relates
to an angle cause we call it because
cosine and it has to be there she's like
which angle you interested in right
because if you stand like cosine right
and I said well that's adjacent and
hypotenuse adjacent to what like which
angle are you talking about okay so
there has to be an angle in there I've
got the officer in the
I've got the adjacent and I have what is
one more pair of missing okay so there's
the opposite side and he Jason so if you
leave out the longest one the hypotenuse
okay we call this guy tangent which we
have three mates okay so now you're like
wait really all of that just to explain
and if you what you're heading down what
we've been doing is we've been measuring
measuring measuring like a metric system
we've been measuring triangles that's
more trigonometry means so what
trigonometry is claria is this mystery
that if you get angles you'll know this
relationship between the sides okay you
get this pattern so can you see you've
got sign obviously that body's cosine
adjacent up on these and ten which is
opposite or adjacent so we have an
acronym to remember this i know if
you've seen it written like this before
yeah yeah that was it what vanilla so
what I'm good here is I'm giving these
ratios this is what this is about ratios
okay
I'm giving them names and this is just a
mnemonic device to remember which ratios
or which names match up together okay so
I say that is sohcahtoa you don't need
to worry about this too much because you
get given a lot of this on your formula
dodgy but it's still nice to actually
have it up here rather than have to go
searching for it somewhere okay all
right now he comes the flood whatever I
said to you mystery number one how did I
know what was going on here and the
answer was similar shapes you made
similar traits shape always by accident
okay mystery number two was why is this
called what it is what does that have to
do with anything what does that even
mean
so to help you understand what's going
on I'm going to forget you to help me by
getting your calculators out now you can
see I'm just gonna punch it off now
clearly we use that as what what two
angles if we went every 15 we could gone
every 10 and done done more numbers okay
but if I join the dots now and now I'd
like you to do the same you can draw
this video you're getting this shape can
you're getting this shape now this is
weird this is really weird we started
with these guys triangles right these
are the simplest slike shapes with
straight lines you can imagine straight
lines that's what they were all that's
why you have to have rules when you're
constructing these things right but out
of that I've noticed this pattern of
ratios and I've trying to say well what
happens with other angles okay
and when I do that I get this shape
which is quite unmistakeably
curved it's not straight at all okay now
the Latin word for curve is sinus that
in fact you all have a sinus in you does
anyone know where your sign is here
that's right I am because in your in
your nasal passage there is a part of it
that is curved okay and that's your
siteís right I have to myself and sir
what about you look at this check that
shape over there we don't need to
understand it so much you see it and
notice that nothing is like that's weird
I started with straight things and by
understanding this relationship is right
here just like mapping it out I got a
curve me they said that's weird
let's call it a curve that's all sinus
means okay now I'll explain that what
these guys are about remember I said we
say cause it's showing you calculators
because it's all about but whose side is
actually an abbreviation it's an
abbreviation where you wrote cosine I'd
like you to write up you what's an
abbreviation for is when it's an
abbreviation for is the complement of
off side now remember we had a look over
here we said side 30 side 30 degrees
rather it's always whatever - whatever -
whatever - there are differences here
but all these discrepancies are
discrepancies of measurement like I said
I couldn't quite get the angle perfectly
well where I measured out my rule has
limits of accuracy and so on
right but really as you can see on your
calculator I feel you touch in cycling
degrees it will faithfully give you back
a half if there were some kind of
perfect triangle that's what the ratio
would be okay